c'est la plus grosse affaire que la
téléréalité est connu et qui fait grand
bruit depuis une semaine je fais caca
dans un truck on fait de la sorcellerie
une mystérieuse histoire de sorcellerie
qui aurait été manigancée par car la
candidate des marseillais et s'il faut
enlever le mariage de julien mannon dans
la prochaine saison et le remplacer par
mois qui viennent on fait c'est le
blogueur marc plata qui révèle
l'information qui diffuse plusieurs
sonore poupée vaudou magie noire
elle s'en serait pris à plusieurs
candidats dont sa meilleure amie m'a
[Applaudissements]
très vite sur les réseaux et dans les
médias tout le monde prend la parole et
les clans se forment
car la dig depuis samedi matin qu'elle
l'a fait sous influence fonds cash flow
citoyens là on touche un sacré de dell
pour certains car la soirée la victime
d'une voyante mal intentionnés dans
cette affaire les rebondissements sont
nombreux et depuis certains ont changé
de camp est ce que carla était
consentante c'est une autre histoire
il y à raquettes mais qui dit vrai que
s'est il vraiment passé au sein de la
grande famille des marseillais ce soir
la principale intéressée car l'amour au
sort du silence dans tpm p
merci à carla moreau d'être avec no
mercy carla merci d'être là et merci à
votre avocat alexandre blais d'être avec
nous merci alexandre pour y être dans
les marseillais vont aussi un passionné
vous avez non mais voilà je le dis alors
pour ceux nés les rares personnes qui me
connaissent pas carla déjà merci d'être
là car là je sais que vous êtes
c'était très stressée de venir sur le
plateau est vraiment voile a été une
semaine facile dossier on va revenir sur
cette semaine déjà
pour ceux qui vous connaissent pas il y
en a très peu je propose qu'on garde un
petit sujet qui résume sa carrière en
tant que candidate de télé-réalité et
influents se tait une des plus grandes
stars des marseillais qui cartonne et
une influence us t'as combien de temps
comme une personne qui te suivent sur un
stage sera millions 3,3 millions 3 voilà
c'est trois millions de plus que castrés
[Rires]
ce soit nous recevons car l'amour ou la
star de télé réalité aux 3,3 millions
d'abonnés elle fait ses débuts en 2007
dans les marseillais saint-affrique a
aidé son arrivée la petite blondinette
transfert déjà l'écran
coucou à ses carrelages j'ai 18 ans et
je viens de recettes
jeune fille pétillante elle séduit tout
de suite les téléspectateurs par son
côté sensible et sa relation tumultueuse
avec un autre candidat kevin une
relation que les fans suivront à travers
chaque saison marseille à versus le
reste du monde moundir elle fera pas
moins de 12 émissions sur w9
kevin finira par la demander en mariage
à new york en 2019
car l'amour
ils donneront naissance la même année à
la petite ruby qui fera l'objet d'une
autre émission kevin plus carla et
galbées ruby une sensation que jamais
c'est vrai que dans la boue bref
aujourd'hui à 24 ans carla est une maman
comblée
pour la première fois dans tpm pl était
avec nous ce soir alors carla
déjà première question c'est est votre
rêve de faire de faire ça pas forcément
moi je travaille dans la coiffure c'est
vrai qu'il y avait envié un petit peu de
changer et il ya eu les marchés qui sont
proposés à moi comment comment vous est
venu vous chercher sur les réseaux
sociaux
d'accord voyants ou mac ou enfin on m'a
contacté j'ai passé un casting et j'ai
été prise mais vouliez pas forcément
faire ça non pas du tout ouvrir mon
salon coiffure j'étais vraiment enfin
quand je fais quelque chose de bas je le
fais à fond je fais rien donc j'étais à
fond dans la coiffure et c'est vrai que
j'en avais un petit peu marre avec mon
patron ça se passait pas forcément super
bien donc je me suis dit bon bah
pourquoi pas c'est vrai que ça me change
nerfs et je sais pas dans quoi je
m'embarquais mais bon c'est l'inconnu on
nie pas et ensuite ça a explosé pour
vous oui un énorme carton et là c'est
vrai que maintenant vous êtes une énorme
star voilà c'était donc c'est vrai je le
vois aujourd'hui c'est incroyable et
tout se passait bien pour vous cette
jeune maman vous avez connu votre votre
fiancée dans l' aventure donc cette
aventure les marseillais vous a tout
donné
les siens j'ai grandi à travers les
marchés l'argent parce que c'est vrai
que c'est avec ce que vous faites aussi
sur les réseaux s'est énormément
d'argent
vous avez connu l'amour vous avez un
enfant aujourd'hui donc tout et tout est
au top au est là la semaine dernière il
ya une histoire qui sort vous accusant
de faire de la sorcellerie sur les
autres candidats selon ses accusateurs
vous auriez demandé une voyante d'user
de la sorcellerie
afin de pouvoir être mises en lumière
dans le programme plus que les autres
mais aussi de nuire à d'autres
candidates de télé réalité déjà avant
que vous me répondiez à toutes ces
questions vous entendez bien vous pouvez
essayer il ya plutôt une bonne entente
est largement temps il ya des fois avec
qui on s'entend - mais ça c'est dans la
vie tous les jours tu savais qu'il
s'entend très bien avec qui tu t'entends
moins bien c'est vrai que la vie en
communauté et pas forcément que des fois
ça éclate son vient de marseille l'ont
forcément qu'on a le sang chaud donc bas
des fois ça se passe bien des fois ça se
passe mal mais il ya toujours un
beaucoup d'amour dans tout ça dans tous
les cas d'accord
tu nous a dit que c'était une semaine
difficile pour toi parce qu'on va revoir
les vidéos qui sont sortis qui
prouverait que tu aurais eu recours à la
sorcellerie
on découvre notamment des rituels
impliquant des poupées vaudou regarder
les factures je les ai en ma possession
j'ai bien regardé et alors et poupées
s'il vous plaît et je voudrais qu'on
voit les poupées merci ça c'était marc
batta qui était terriblement w9 et la
production et se fasse virer de mon dieu
ils devront se séparer de miles a
rapidement et instantanément et que car
l'art de vienne et vienne à tout jamais
la première des candidates de télé
[Applaudissements]
tournage alors c'est vrai que ça c'était
les vidéos qu'on a vu la semaine
dernière la personne qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure c'était marc batta qui est un
blogueur qui a révélé cette affaire et
vous allez voir qu'il a fait d'autres
vidéos aujourd'hui pour se rétracter
on va voir ça dans un instant carla donc
ce qui vous est reproché c'est davos et
d'avoir fait de la sorcellerie sur des
candidats de télé réalité pour l'heure
vouloir du mal et pour voilà on dit que
la sorcellerie
ça peut marcher expliquez-nous cette
histoire parce que alors déjà je voulais
vous remercier de pouvoir me prendre je
puisse prendre la parole parce que c'est
vrai que ça fait mon boulot de vérité
que je ne parle pas sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est vrai que j'ai entendu
beaucoup de choses qui se sont dit à mon
égard
les choses devraient des choses face ça
n'a pas été évident et c'est vrai que
ben moi je suis venu ici pour vous
raconter mon histoire bien ce qui s'est
réellement passé depuis le début mois à
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que j'ai consultés cette voyante à 17 18
ans aujourd'hui avait un aujourd'hui on
est 24
ce sont donc j'étais absolument pas
reconnu absolument pas les marseillais
j'ai consulté parce qu'entre amis on se
disait à la voyante s'écoule bas
peut-être qu'on peut lire notre futur
ben pourquoi pas autant essayer
je suis donc enfin j'ai donc taper sur
l'internet bat voyante sur marseille
d'adrien c'est juste vous avez tapé sur
un terroir sont le premier nom c'était
celui ci incroyable j'y suis allé
d'accord
j'y suis allé j'ai fait une consultation
classique ou tout simplement moi je sais
même plus si ce qu'elle me disait
c'était vrai ou faux mais bon je trouve
ça assez rigolo bombardier 10 à 18 ans
j'avais 17 18 ans avec ses potes de
l'époque n'ont pas du tout été dans la
coiffure donc à est absolument rien
d'autre qui se passe je fais cette
consultation et je ne vois plus cette
personne là je la vois plus ah oui je
continue ma vie je continue mon métier
de coiffeuse et à un moment donné donc
vient ce casting des marseillais dans
quelle langue
absolument rien j'ai entendu beaucoup de
gens qui m'ont dit mais non elle a eu
peut-être ça pour passer à la télé non
absolument pas cette dame m'a recontacté
à la suite de ma diffusion à la télé
quoi vous sert à pas elle vous elle m'a
rappelé pascal havet mon numéro en fait
puisé nationale s'est dit c'est la jeune
fille qui avec elle s'est rappelée deux
mois de qui j'étais et sur tel est mon
numéro de téléphone
donc moi je vois pas où est le mal j'ai
eu un bon feeling avec cette personne
elle me dit qu'elle a envie de me voir
parce qu'elle m'a vu à travers la télé
donc je me dis pourquoi pas je vois pas
où est le mal pourquoi pas en repartir
dans son cabinet à ce moment là elle
m'explique voilà qu'elle est content de
m'avoir vu
elle me laissait ya un petit peu de
savoir ce qui s'est passé elle avait
vraiment une relation un peu amicales
avec moi ou elle me disait bon bah c'est
bien mais maintenant qu'est ce que tu
veux dans ta vie comme tout le monde moi
je souhaite réussir je souhaite repartir
dans les aventures je souhaite trouver
un shérif qu'ils soient gentils qu'ils
soient fidèles j'espère avoir des beaux
enfants j'espère bien gagner ma vie
comme tout le monde
ah ok bon bain à plusieurs donc on se
fait plusieurs rendez-vous à travers ça
où est le métier j'étais moi je vois ça
je vois ça pour toi mais je me voyais
plus ou moins je sais plus combien tri g
2 mai fc2 tu étais devenu open car là
c'est à dire les antennes confie donc
voilà une petite fille dans ce blog n'a
mis que envie de vénérer d'accord je
suis mon père oui une amie où je me
disais je veux mon bien moi je vous
raconte un peu ce qui se passe je j'ai
confiance en n ya rien de mal et puis
arrive un moment donné ou écoutent carla
faut vraiment que je te vois donc je
suis marocaine
qu'est ce qui se passe il vous appelle
pour vous faut vraiment que je te revois
j'ai alors moi je me dis peut-être qu'un
flash peut-être car oui elle m'a dit
quelque chose je sais pas donc je vais
la voir à son domicile où la basse est
pas l est pas seul
d'accord allait avec une dizaine de
personnes parce que c'est comme ça
qu'ils vivent donc une dizaine de
personnes je me dis ouah qu'est ce qui
se passe je comprends pas mais tu sais
moi tu m'as parlé que j'avais envie
de réussir ta vie tu m'as parlé que
j'avais envie de gagner de l'argent nous
sommes excusés moi je peux réaliser tous
âges ah bon mais comment bah oui je peux
réaliser tout ça mais pour ça il va
falloir que tu me formule des choses que
je vais te dis que tu es mais je
comprends pas mais oui c'est pour que
j'arrive à voir si réellement ça va je
vais apporter des ondes positives donc
ça la chance va t'arriver parce que tu
sais moi j'ai des dons aux rockets
d'accord donc là à ce moment là je me
dis battue c'est alors que je formule
certaines choses moi le problème c'est
que j'ai une pression parce que je me
retrouve avec 10 personnes autour de moi
je ne connais pas des hommes des femmes
je me dis mais qu'est ce qui se passe
derrière tout ça moi j'ai qu'une envie
c'est de vite partir le fait que tant
que je formulais pas ce genre de choses
elle ne me laissait pas partir
moi je me dis mon demande de formuler
des choses mais qui vont pas avec ce que
j'ai envie parce que je m'estime attends
moi je veux juste être heureux dans ma
vie je ne comprends pas pourquoi tu veux
me faire du mal faire du mal à mon
entourage
oui mais même le même ma maman il va
falloir que tu t'es tâche un peu ta
maman mais moi je vais jouer ouais ok
moi je me détache d'accord et à ce
moment là je prends tout chez moi quand
je rentre chez moi donc déjà je sentais
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui n'allait
pas chantier - et à ce moment là une
balance des vidéos des vidéos comme vous
avez pu le voir et là je me suis dit
qu'est ce que c'est mais je comprends
pas moi j'ai pas de chute ou de demander
ça c'est c'est quoi ça mais des vidéos
d'auto personnes détenues dans des
vidéos un peu dans ce style là qu'on a
pu déjà découvrir d'accord moi je me dis
mais moi j'ai aimé ça je comprends pas
ah si si tu m'a demandé ça mais
maintenant il va falloir payer au moins
je sais pas demandez ça si si mais
maintenant rappelle toi que costumes à
formuler ses demandes moi je t'ai
enregistré d'accord c'est à dire qu'à
vous disais par exemple voilà est-ce que
tu aimerais pas être plus la star des
loyers peau sur les os c'est formule le
mois et nîmois pas là je n'ai pas besoin
de directives et on me dit en me faisant
faire des choses que j'avais pas envie
parce que ça allait pas si c'est pas un
genre oui ben alors j'ai envie d'être
promu bon ok je suis connue non moi je
comprend pas vraiment ce qui se passe et
la haine auxquels vous enregistrez votre
émission juste à mon argent - 38 et
d'ailleurs c'est sa manière de pratiquer
c'est qu'à chaque fois elle enregistrer
les choses moi je comprends pas et là je
me dis mais moi pourquoi je suivais mon
argent donc elle me demande une femme
qui était minime à l'époque mais qui
était déjà beaucoup pour mon york je ne
gagne pas je suis plus là et demandez
peut-être 200 300 500 euros je sais plus
mais c'était déjà beaucoup pour moi
parce que moi je gagnais pas ce que je
gagnais à l'heure d'aujourd'hui donc
donc je moi je me dis mon dieu mais
comment je vais faire parce que
maintenant je suis connue et maintenant
ils ont ils ont
ces fameuses notes dont je suis pas fier
que j'ai dit parce que ils ont obligé de
le dire mais comment je vais faire pour
m'en sortir
donc je motive j'ai pas d'autre choix
que de devoir payer peut-être pour
qu'elle me laisse tranquille dont
voulait donner 500 euros donc je lui
donne je sais plus combien ct mais voilà
je paye et là à ce moment là je
comprends que je suis parti dans quelque
chose qui me dans l'engrenage
parce que là c'était a même un nom va
être au contact et il nous fallait je
suis nous redonne de l'argent mais
comment je vais donner de l'argent déjà
beaucoup de souplesse tranquille oui
mais non parce que maintenant il va
falloir faire de nouvelles choses
oui mais je comprends pas parce que si
tu ne veux pas vous devez pas que la
première la première chose avec tt note
donc si tu veux pas que ça sorte que tu
veux pas avoir de soucis il va falloir
que tu continues à payer et j'étais dans
cet engrenage en permanence au corps
pour résumer donc première fois vous
allez enfin vous allez une fois donc
c'est cette brillante deux appels qui
vous dit il faut que vous éloignez faut
que je te vois elle vous fait faire des
choses voilà ferme raconter ma vie en
fait on ne fait pas les intéressent
personne elle vous enregistrez derrière
elle vous fait un premier chantage après
donc elle vous fait revenir hélas elle
vous fait faire ce genre de vidéos la
non moi je n'ai jamais fait ce genre de
vidéos moi elle me fait fermer des notes
comme quoi ils prouvent que c'est bel et
bien moi qui veut ça et pas et pas elle
mais en me dictant et en me disant mais
il va faire tu formule c'est de cette
manière parce que si tu veux pas avoir
de soucis c'est comme ça qu'il va
falloir le faire
donc moi je mets 10 mai mais comment je
vais faire pour m'en sortir
malheureusement je suis connue moi j'ai
pas envie de perdre mon travail parce
que s'il ya ça qui sort donc penser que
je suis folle donc vous aviez leurs
gammes saviez peur que ça sorte pour les
marseillais que vous l'ayez pour me pour
ma vie je me dis mon votre carrière
comment est-ce que c'est quoi cette
somme de 1,2 million d'abonnés auriez
donné à la brillante 1,2 million d'euros
il paraît que c'est mme bresso et c'est
une vraie salle où j'avais donc donné ça
va ça a duré sur plusieurs années sur
combien d'années sur à peu près à jouer
j'ai plus la notion sur sa tranche 4 du
rafale sur quatre ans donc sur quatre
ans elle vous alexandre et ses 1,2
million d'euros le problème c'est que
comme les paiements devenait de plus en
plus cher parce que je pense qu'elle
devait voir que vous demandez combien
pascal sur les terres de plus en plus ça
a était quoi 500 euros puis quoi ensuite
après c'est emile et puis après steppa
mills étaient 6000 et puis après cpu
1000 et puis en fait après ça ne
s'arrêtait plus à dire qu'elle me
laisser absolument aucun argent pour que
moi je puisse vivre parce que un million
deux cent mille euros sur quatre ans il
faut les avoir déjà et ça oui mais après
j'ai réussi c'est ma ville mois à
travers ça et je pense qu'elle va soyez
pas ce que je pouvais pas lui mentir moi
c'était sur les réseaux sociaux
moi quand je faisais mes placements
quand je quand je passais la télé le
voyait donc elle savait j'étais même
arriver au stade où je me disais quand
je m'achète quelque chose il faut
surtout pas que je le montre
parce que si moi je m'achète un sac à
main ils vont se dire que j'en ai encore
de l'argent me tout irait donc il
fallait que j'arrête il fallait que je
me cache pour que je dise
un merci kevin merci de m'avoir acheter
ce sac à main merci de m'avoir acheter
ça parce que je me disent s'ils voient
que j'ai encore de l'argent ils vont
tous me prendre j'étais arrivé au stade
je me dis il va falloir je n'ai pas eu
toute ma vie parce que en fait je suis
parti dans un engrenage où je pouvais
plus faire machine arrière
alors ces six vidéos comment ils sont
sortis commencé ces informations car ce
blogueur tout ça moi je alors c'est là
où j'en viens c'est qu'en fait ils ont
commencé à me demander d'aider des
sommes beaucoup plus grosse et moi je
leur combat à des sommes à des 50 le web
voilà jusque-là par par mois en fait ça
quand le loup robert effectivement et
moi le problème c'est que bien sûr je
les avais pas au niveau personnel je ne
les avais pas de prendre une société
donc moi je me retrouve à me dire mais
je ne peux plus te payer juger une
société maintenant mois - au début je me
suis dit je vais pouvoir m'en sortir
parce que j'ai une société mais non car
la taille est pas y avait toujours une
solution mais non quand la taille est
pas je vais t'emmener à mon avocat on a
loupé un va te faire un contrat un
contrat bidon mon comptable à te faire
des factures mes factures bidon mais ça
va juste se fiancer paiement là et puis
surtout moi je fais ça mais c'est parce
que justement il ya derrière
je ne veux donc en fait c'est un
engrenage vous l'avez toujours des
solutions le problème c'est que moi je
savais que je faisais quelque chose une
faute pour ma société je savais que je
faisais quelque chose de mal mais
malheureusement moi j'étais menacé parce
que il n'y avait pas que ce genre de
vidéos c'est qu'il ya eu des menaces
aussi oui mais tu sais car la section
paye pas et va t'arriver des malheurs il
va arriver des malheurs à ta famille à
ta maman
donc moi forcément parce que j'ai
entendu plusieurs personnes qui m'ont
dit mais tu as du caractère car là bien
sûr j'ai du caractère à travers des
aventures de deux membres en dedans je
sais me défendre mais quand menace ta
famille qu'est ce qu'on fait à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui kan menacent sa famille
ont mis ses menaces à exécution
parce qu'ils sont allés chez ma mère
pendant que j'étais en tournage pendant
sept ans tournage me contacter mais moi
j'étais en tournage pouvait rien faire
ah bon mais je vais aller chez sa mère
de soutirer date des chèques de l'argent
ma mère ne savait pas comment faire pour
s'en sortir qu'ils allaient jusqu'à chez
elle
oui mais madame si vous payez pas il va
vous arriver des soucis ma mère qu'est
ce qu'elle a fait elle a payé par contre
une faction après le tournage est
magique car la maintenance
s'arrête il va falloir prévenir la
police il ya deux ans de ça il y en a
plein qui ont 10 mai à calais comme il
ya deux ans pas mais en a porté plainte
avec mon beau père je le savais barande
moi je n'ai pas porté plainte parce que
j'avais peur de ces gens j'avais peur
qu'ils mettent leur menace à exécution
donc j'ai laissé faire ça oui vous aviez
peur de porter plainte aussi pour que
parce qu'elle voulait dire si cette
histoire si on sait que c'est moi elle
va s'en prendre à moi et elle va mettre
ses menaces à exécution chose qu'elle a
fait à l'envi donc ça veut dire que vous
viviez sous pression depuis des années
jeudi les suppressions mais ce qui me
rassure et c'était que de me dire ce
qu'elle est temps que je paye ms
tranquille mais payer tous les mois un
moment c'est insupportable je sais c'est
1,2 million d'euros nous avait donné
dexim à cette voyante allons vous allez
nous donner d'autres infos dans un
instant parce que l incroyable histoire
juste suite à cette histoire de youssef
sissaoui le président de l'ina de
l'institut national des arts
divinatoires s'est totalement
désolidarisé de cette fausse voyante
fosses sorcière qui seraient dépourvus
de dons je vous propose de regarder ce
qu'il a dit sur cette affaire garde je
suis le président de l'ina institut
national des arts divinatoires un
organisme spécialisé dans la défense des
consommateurs et la moralisation de la
profession caussade ronda et donc il
s'agit nous la connaissons pour avoir eu
affaire à elle nous avons signalé des
siens en 2014
nous l'avons informée qu'elle avait eu
ni connaissance ni compétence en matière
d'art dînatoire et encore moins à s'en
sortir et d'aller elle fait partie d'une
coque de sorciers de sorcières sans
compétence ni connaissance qui profite
d'une situation d'une section de
fragilité extraordinaire de clients et
de clientes sont déconnectés de la
réalité
donc faut dire tout simplement en
conclusion qu'elle n'a aucun gant elle
lui un seul don cas là c'est de savoir
manipuler les gens ça pour gagner de
l'argent
alors voilà sans que c'était important
d'avoir donc ce ce témoignage juste
honte a donc karl a donc accusé de
sorcellerie notamment envers maeva qui
serait ta meilleure amie
qu'est-ce que tu réponse à ce que ce que
tu a émis en aucun cas j'ai souhaité du
mal et encore moins ma meilleure jamais
souhaité mal jamais qu'un jamais le
problème
j'ai été contraint par quelques notes
qu'elle me soutirer ne te voir des fois
dire un homme il faut faire ça parce que
sinon tu vas part il est ce que j mais
moi je veux plus y arriver auquel vous
et dire des chaussures maeva sur my back
deux personnes se servait se disait que
ça c'est votre meilleure amie ça exagéré
de n'obtenir je vais pouvoir la tenir à
travers ça et comme ça elle va forcément
continuer à payer parce que si ça sera
grand jour ça va être un carnage
donc elle continuait à instaurer ça avec
moi le problème c'est que moi j'étais
contraint de donner cet argent pour
qu'ils me laissent tranquille parce que
j'avais peur aussi pour ma vie j'avais
peur pour ma maman
il était déjà venu à plusieurs fins à
plusieurs reprises récupérer des chèques
j'étais vraiment dans la peur et j'étais
terrifié de ce qu'ils étaient capables
de faire
donc moi ce que je veux ce qui me
rassure et quelques en quelque sorte
c'était de me dire bon je leur donne cet
argent je sais qu'ils vont pas menacé ma
famille et moi je sais qu'ils vont
prendre l'argent mais par contre je suis
soulagé parce que je sais que ce n'est
absolument pas une sorcière
je sais que même ce qu'ils peuvent faire
sur ces vidéos la san accablera en rien
mes amis parce que moi ces gens là ce
mois mes amis et encore plus maeva
clément meilleur ami alors là il va
aujourd'hui comment ça se passe avec
votre meilleur niveau aujourd'hui et
c'est ce que je pense d'elle lcl vous
accrue baala dans votre histoire
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui on a on n'a pas
besoin de parler elle sait ce que je
pense d'elle et je sais ce qu'elle pense
de vous être parlé depuis où c'est mon
ami ça le restera
vous êtes reparlé depuis la science et
reparler et aller à la haye l'a compris
elle a compris parce que ça a été
compliqué pour elle de forcément c'est
légitime
je suis voit sa loge sur 10 mais je
comprends pas ma meilleure amie enfin on
a toujours été ensemble pour partager
les plus grand secret pourquoi elle me
ferais ça et après une fois qu on
discute
une fois que j'ai dit plus discuter et
lui montrer réellement ce que ce qui se
passait elle a compris et je sais que
vous êtes victime de racket et de
chantage
oui bah oui donc et l'extorsion fait que
de 1,2 million d'euros aux normes oui et
aux gens là on a le témoignage de carla
moi j'ai reçu le témoignage d'une autre
jeune femme qui aurait été victime de
cette même dana et donc de cette même
voyante elle lui reproche exactement la
même chose en substance un elle aurait
été sous l'emprise de cette voyante de
il y aurait eu de grosses sommes
d'argent à peut-être pas autant vous
parce qu'elle n'a pas les mêmes moyens
mais qu'ils ont été réclamés et 3a c'est
ça le point important c'est cette
voyante qui aurait demandé à ces deux
jeunes femmes de jeter des sorts pour
nuire à son entourage
par exemple lui disais voilà quelqu'un
va perdre son enfant dans ta famille si
tu ne veux pas que ça arrive à toi il
faut que tu te demandes que ça arrive à
ta belle soeur par exemple donc c'est
cette voie non seulement elle prenait de
l'argent mais en plus elle demandé aux
personnes de jeter des sorts à leur
entourage et d'être malveillants envers
leur entourage
donc c'est pas un cas isolé en tout cas
selon les témoignages que gilles verdez
selon mes informations la voyante danaé
à une complicité avec une
dames qui se présente comme sorcière
qu'on a vu sur les réseaux sociaux warda
je pense que vous êtes au courant oui
mais je la connais je n'ai pas jijel et
le système était presque un système
mafieux c'est à dire que vous avez eu
chez vous dans votre famille des hommes
de main qui sont venus il ya eu des
sorts qui ont été jetés avec des voyants
africains qui vous ont menacé donc
l'extorsion de fonds selon mes
informations étaient vraiment huilé
c'est un système qui étaient autour de
vous est ce que vous confirmer ces
informations
moi ce que je confirme c'est que oui
avait enfin il y avait de la
manipulation près de moi de l'emprise de
la peur aussi et de la honte de me dire
mon dieu mais je peux même pas en parler
je peux même pas avertir mes proches de
ce qui se passe parce que c'était un
poids terrible pour moi pendant des
années ça a été très compliqué et même
si là à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
ce que je vis compliqué parce que je
dois me justifier auprès des personnes
parce que c'est difficile de voir ce
genre de vidéos
je suis malgré tout soulagé que ça sorte
parce que je me dis ça y est elles ont
mis leur menace à exécution
j'ai une protection parce que maintenant
j'ai pris une protection pour nous pour
vous former demeurant me permettrait
d'être en sécurité chez moi mais
maintenant le chantage déterminées elles
ne pourront plus demander de l'argent
c'est fini vous êtes plutôt soulagé donc
cette histoire oui je suis ça a été
difficile
la promesse que ces derniers forment et
vendée contre de vivre comme ça on y
vend 3 en réseau je vais même vous dire
mieux mais ma famille m'ont dit mais
j'ai l'impression de te retrouver il ya
quatre ans de ça parce que tu t'étais
renfermé totalement et maintenant où te
retrouves comme à l'époque
vous avez peur aujourd'hui ou plus ou
moins j'ai en fait j'avais c'est dur de
se dire vous mettez à payer toute ta vie
pour que rien ne sorte pour parce que
c'était un chantage constants tu as payé
tout allait pour qu'il n'ait pas de
soucis après ta famille et maintenant ça
sort au grand jour c'est difficile mais
après au bout de quelques jours je me
suis dit mais en vrai je suis soulagé
parce que maintenant les gens ils ont
compris la vérité et maintenant je peux
enfin me justifier les prendre parole de
ce qui se passait maintenant je vais
plus mentir aux gens c'est fini vous
aurait porté plainte
j'ai porté plainte votre avocat et là
qu'est ce qui va se passer maintenant
et les téléspectateurs écoutez j'ai
entendu la dernière fois il ya quelques
jours que l avait déposé plainte
tardivement
effectivement mais il y avait déjà une
plainte qui a été déposée il ya un an et
demi par ses proches parce qu'ils se
sont rendus compte de ce qui se passait
elle l'avait caché pendant des années
donc elle a vécu un calvaire
le dixième personne et c'est quand ses
proches sa mère son beau-père ont été
eux mêmes contacté même pour inciter
carla à donner des chèques ou ce que les
chèques soient honorées et c'est que
finalement eux mêmes ils ont pris la
décision de déclencher le processus
judiciaire c'était il ya un an et demi
ça a pris un peu de temps et finalement
cette danaé a subi ne garde à vue suite
à cette plainte
le mois dernier une enquête en cours oui
tout à fait oui donc dès que après cette
menace justement de sortir toutes ses
preuves tout ces éléments soit disant
contre carla qui ont été fabriqués par
cette cette voyante et toute son équipe
elle s'est sentie libérée elle est allée
déposer plainte donc c'était il ya
quelques jours et nous avons été entendu
vendredi matin par les policiers pour
développer toute la planète et tous les
éléments
est ce qu'il y avait d'autres cas comme
la digue il y en a plusieurs mais je
suis aussi sur ce plateau pour dire ben
de plus à avoir peur parce que je pense
que moi j'ai la chance d'être dans la
lumière et de pouvoir en parler ou ici
sur ce plateau mais je sais qu'il ya
énormément de personnes qui ont eu la
même chose que moi alors oui bien sûr
financièrement beaucoup moins élevé mais
ça reste de l'argent sur 100 euros à
quelqu'un qui en payent jmil c'est
exactement la même chose c'est du
chantage et durera quelques jours et
c'est pour ça que je suis aussi là c'est
pour dire ne plus avoir peur et que si
je peux être aussi là pour les autres je
le ferai alors carla qu'est-ce que vous
avez ajouté ce soit si je vous laisse
si j'ai ce que j'ai adressé aux
téléspectateurs parce que ça fait une
histoire incroyable il ya plein de
gentil mais on voulait il ya des gens
qui vous ont défendu jusqu'à la fin ça a
été des semaines et des jours très très
compliqué pour vous aujourd'hui qu'est
ce que vous avez envie de dire à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui ce que j'ai envie de dire
c'est déjà de m'excuser auprès des
marseillais de toutes les personnes qui
ont été impliquées par sept par cette
affaire parce que malgré tout ils ont
rien demandé et c'est vrai que quand ils
ont découvert tout ça non pas une
inversion des choses donc je peux
comprendre qu'ils aient été énervé je
m'en excuse parce que moi les marchés ça
fait partie de ma famille malgré tout
j'ai grandi à travers eux j'ai rencontré
le père de ma fille j'ai évolué donc
c'est je veux qu'il comprenne que il ya
en aucun cas j'ai souhaité du mal et en
aucun cas cette femme et avaient des
drones de sorcellerie
et des sorts qui non plus envoyé non
c'est pas le cas donc je m'en excuse
auprès d'eux est à présent j'ai envie de
me consacrer vraiment à ma famille je
remercie vraiment d'ailleurs kevin ma
famille ma belle famille qui ont été là
pour moi et surtout le soutien de toutes
les personnes sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est énorme et c'est grâce à ça que
j'ai pu me relever et me dire non n'ai
pas honte
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui tu as subi ça il
faut que les gens le sachent pas ce que
ça peut aider aussi d'autres personnes
et maintenant c'est bel et bien terminé
je démarre une nouvelle vie alors donc
et une enquête en cours on a eu votre
version des faits ce soir merci à vous
d'avoir été sur soit on dirait que je
sais que c'était pas évident ça va ça
s'est bien passé
voilà en tout cas vous avez pu notre
exposé que nous exposer votre vérité